[Musique]
très bon soir peter oliver merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france 9
heures d'âpres négociations comme
souvent d'ailleurs entre la chancelière
et les dirigeants des seize est un
régions du pays hier la chancelière qui
a dû céder face au mécontentement
croissant de la population allemande
des stocks' de big and switch and soul
conversation entre la chancelière et le
dirigeant des 16 états régionaux ont
cours depuis le 5 novembre et l'âme
avant les concessions toujours été très
tendue ce que nous avons constaté hier
c'est une variation la plus difficile et
la plusieurs premier a toujours plutôt
n'en ai dû donner
donc il ya eu des échanges de documents
entre eux son conseil le matériel et l
échange d état allemand
elle souhaitait que le déconfinement se
fasse le 28 mars elle a obtenu cela elle
voulait également les restrictions grand
ne soient assouplies savons que lorsque
on atteignait un taux d'incidence de 35
cas par 100 milles à dieter elle a dû
reculer sur ce point et ils sont tombés
d'accord sur 50 pour cent mille âmes et
nous reviendrons a déçu bientôt iphone
c'est donc la patience effectivement
c'est depuis les avec le confinement en
allemagne les dirigeants des régions se
sentent excès ont résisté c'est entre la
volonté de la chancelière et et cela a
été vrai tout au long de la crise les
gouvernements régionaux tous pour une
réouverture de la commune est bien plus
rapide que le souhaiterait le
gouvernement fédéral à berlin
et cela continue on car la grande peur
du gouvernement fédéral
la grandeur des scientifiques et des
épidémiologistes manière c
les variants de la cofidis neuf pourrait
avoir un effet sur la population
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut le rappeler
contrairement au président macron ils
sont vraiment à l'opposé au gala macron
j'allais dire en gala merkel et emmanuel
macron y en a un qui veut vraiment par
confiner ça sera le dernier recours et
il faut rappeler que la chancelière elle
a toujours été sur cette stratégie le
confinement at on pris pour maintenir la
santé de la nation bien sûr ne seront
pas être vraiment là comptent bien sûr
s'apprête à partir à la retraite
voilà je crois que c'est tout dit en
deux phrases effectivement peter en tout
cas la stratégie du gouvernement
allemand s'appuie sur le déploiement de
tests antigénique s'était pas déjà le
cas en allemagne ces tests antigénique
ya aujourd'hui notamment par la voix du
ministère de la santé
c'est qu'ils vont déployer de nouveaux
tests de millas plus efficace plus
performants qui seront disponibles
gratuitement très souvent dans de
nombreux endroits et cela qu'on ciblait
avec elle la vaccination c'est le fond
de la stratégie du gouvernement allemand
qui permettra de maîtriser
la vide ce nom on agit qu il cherche à
atteindre ce nombre de 54% du vita pour
mettre en place ce plan graduelle qui se
composera de 5e étape à prendre les
terres parce que c'était le 1er mars les
écoles ont pu réouvrir est la seconde
étape au show man / j marseille
mais bon tout l'hyper il est fait pour
mieux ouvrir à goma dans l'est région on
est en dessous de 50 4% mais les musées
de son jeu pourrait également ouvrir son
nom pas très loin pour le moment ce
jeudi celle deux états remplissent ces
critères de 54% aux habitants c'est la
règle à latina et le schleswig holstein
ces deux états pourraient ouvrir leur
commerce
mais dans d'autres états tels que la
thuringe en dépasse les 100 cas pour
ceux habitant de l'ex fis prochaine
serait le 22 mars si le nombre de 50 car
il y aurait davantage de réouverture
répond si on atteint le 5 avril
encore d'autres commerces et d'autres
institutions pourront rouvrir mais il y
aura une conférence avant cela entre la
chancelière et les dirigeants des états
le 24 mars et ils réviseront reverront
la façon dont le couple d'été
confinement se fait et évalueront si on
peut continuer pour renforcer des
mesures et autres sujets évidemment
comme partout à peter lee byrne
la vaccination et la lenteur de la
campagne de vaccination
tout comme en france d'ailleurs qui
exaspère de plus en plus les allemands
ne s'est pas bien passé le gouvernement
allemand ne peuvent pas le tournis
positivement ils n'ont pas bien gérer le
déploiement vaccinale et en europe les
prix ont bien réussi leur déploiement
samedi 2 3% les allemands ont reçu lors
que les premières doses de vaccination
les coms opéré un revirement total
concernant le vaccin astrazeneca
au départ le gouvernement disait qu'il
n'est pas assez d'information et pouvoir
personnel et des personnes de plus de 65
ans avec cette action est aujourd'hui
ils disent que toi la formation et qu'on
doit espaces et les deux donc c'est le
contrat ce qui n'était auparavant les
allemands comme gut animé plusieurs mois
de retard et la campagne de
sensibilisation a été très étrange
concernant le vaccin astrazeneca
je vise ici je travaille cinq je suis
britannique enfin fait longtemps granum
accent et entendre ma famille me parler
du vaccin astrazeneca mes parents l'ont
reçue et ensuite comparer cela à la
politique allemande qui est de ne pas le
donner aux personnes de plus de 65 ans
et c'est très bizarre et le gouvernement
allemand s'étant ligne est maintenant
sur la position française est beaucoup
d'allemands sont très mécontents du
programme de vaccination le gouvernement
ne te pour changer les serrures du passé
ils peuvent que changer l'avenir ils ont
changé de position concernant la grâce
astrazeneca et ils ont deux doses en
stock en allemagne qui peuvent commencer
à distribuer à ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin
ça changera peut être la donne
effectivement et la manne qui s'ouvre
aussi aux vaccins spoutnik verront leur
appel puisque un gars la marque elle
s'est dit prêt à en commander le
spoutnik v qui étudiait à partir
d'aujourd'hui par l' agence du
médicament européenne merci à vous peter
oliver d'avoir été avec nous
correspondons berthet à berlin pour vu
de l'extérieur